[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don Sock'em
today we have the pleasure of sitting
down with David Solomon hi it's great to
be here thank you for coming on to the
show thanks for inviting me I appreciate
it yeah thank you I love your color yeah
it's fun just to dress in the
interdimensional intergalactic fun be a
painting nough so people say this is
more like festival clothes and ID I like
feeling life is a festival yes I think
that the more colorful my sock drawer
becomes the more colorful my life
becomes I think there there's a lot of
magical resonance than that yeah your
life is so colorful well it's
interesting there's a lot of psychology
with color and a lot of energetic stuff
with color yeah if you think about
chakras and chakra tounament spirit
science says this really well they have
like this 42 minutes series on chakras
and they say if you want to take in the
energy of a certain chakra like your
core for will or red for passion root
grounding where that color be surrounded
by it so it goes a step further if you
wear all colors you can sense feel see
and bring in and a lot of times when
people bring all back what they don't
know is they're insulating themselves
energetically so we may not be taking
energy in we may not be putting energy
out it can be protective but can also be
kind of really like isolating not really
pulling that stuff in and if you think
about the personalities and the vibes of
people you know who walk into a room
just all black suits versus the bright
colorful stuff yeah yeah yours a lot
that can be done there you're already
growing right into and I love it I love
it so for those that don't know David
has a background teaching and learning
and especially in magic magic is real is
your page you guys are over a hundred
thousand people I've liked the page and
are engaged in it so it's you're
obviously pushing out content that
people enjoy and that they find to be a
little bit serial mystical spiritual
things that are definitely not like you
said the suits the dark-colored suits
with ties but more so these colors and
why they access us to these different
dimensions of reality that we may not be
tuned to all the time actually maybe
this is
maybe this is important now since we're
already here but the idea that what we
think is a direct part of how we
experience life so for example having
this super rational logical mind all the
time versus having the super emotional
and feeling vulnerable mind all the time
so is there a way to balance those out
yeah I think I think you know for each
of us it's it's different like it
depends where we're coming from and
there's nothing wrong with wearing suits
and dressing in black and being a
monochromatic I mean it can work very
very well in certain contexts just for
the energetic anchor that I personal use
that I personally like I find that a lot
of times there's anchors of
consciousness for who and what we are
and what we want to be if you think
about what is a life what is our life we
could have our intent what we design
what we wish something to be and then
flow what we feel is true for us so
intent is more I'm gonna decide what my
purpose is and then a schedule out my
day I'm gonna get these things done I'm
going to you know where the specific
type of bracelet that works with
personality integration integration of
past parallel simultaneous lives and
astral projection wearing this has an
effect that also is a reminder for me to
keep my consciousness on those topics
because I find they're very useful for
what I'm doing right now and and you're
wearing something that reminds you to
tune into your past present and future
lives as well as astral projection
now most people obviously don't think
about those things so can you unpack
that for us what do you what do you mean
by past present future lives in astral
projection
so the the short answer is in 3d linear
regular everyday time-space reality time
kind of goes like this past is over here
futures over here and we're right here
in the now but if you think about
reality as a whole a lot of the
spiritual teachers and leaders a lot of
the great ones say there is only now and
time isn't like this which is horizontal
10 is like this which is vertical so it
really depends on the orientation that
you want to have if you think oh you
have a past life that was a genius
scientist or a rock
God or a fashionista or really fit or
really inspiring or a great romantic and
you want to tap into that past life or
tap into it for some other reason maybe
to heal a wound affect your personality
in a certain way then it's much easier
to think of life's and lifetimes not
just you know oh maybe 3000 years ago I
had this incarnation in ancient Egypt I
have to get a hold of that name and that
identity realizing that it's all now if
you go 9th dimensional unity where
everything is 1 in the system of magic
that I where we got to break down a
little bit more because this is again we
got it let's start let's start unpacking
more so this this directly relates to
reincarnation then is that true yeah do
you want me just to wrap up the tiny bit
of astral projection do that and then we
got a ninth dimension then we have
reincarnation yeah so let's do those for
sure yeah there's a lot of math yeah so
when when you as awareness not mind not
body but you as awareness shift your
perspective really fully to something
other than your immediate physical
surroundings you can call that astral
projection and you can get very accurate
with it and you can also call it remote
viewing in certain systems and when
you're accurate with it you can see
things accurately that may not be right
in front of you in this time-space
reality that you're in and so a purpose
of something like this or colors or
things to remind you and the value of
all the past life stuff and what we're
about to get into is to really become
whole who are we and how is that useful
how does that play into magic and the
last thing is what's the everyday
practical value of all the stuff is it
just philosophy no is it wishful
thinking no it has actual practical
value in affecting our life and the
day-to-day and it's very heavy
so our physical reality is what is in
front of us and that is limited to the
3-dimensional reality that we experience
here and what we are describing right
now is we're describing something things
that exist outside of our perceptions of
light reflecting off of objects and us
perceiving it smelling and tasting it
etc so astral projection can then be
summed up by saying that is just
removing your thoughts from your skull
into
other areas that's a component of it so
we have we have all these dimensions
overlapping and without getting into all
of them we have the 3d world like time
space matter materialism stuff we pretty
much understand and we're using science
to understand it and control it more and
more but we pretty much have an
understanding time and space so what
astral is as you can say astral
energetic I use the term in my system
and that's that's fourth dimensional
stuff in my system so in the third
dimension to travel you walk across the
room you get in a car you get in a plane
yeah what does it mean as your astral
body as your soul psychic stuff what
does it mean to move or shift well it's
not the same time space map you could
have a lot of overlapping energies
between my hands astrally there can be
energies of fire electricity magnetism
earth there could be dinosaur poop 65
million years ago in the same space-time
chunk right in this little pocket and so
when you do astral travel astral
projection you're taking your awareness
and you're moving it elsewhere and so
that elsewhere you have two ways of
looking at it you have the astral and
you have the physical and you can unlock
a lot of doors once you realize stepping
above the third dimension you can access
all of it in all of time and space with
the right training and practice and
validation which is really key to show
the difference between a delusion and an
actual perception I like that that's a
good way to put it body has to travel to
the bathroom or body can travel with its
soul with its spirit to this energy to a
different location yeah I mean
everything is a fractal of everything
else so a lot of times if people are on
it to a certain type of journey or have
enhanced perceptions we see fractals we
see mirrors we've heard the phrase
consciousness as a Hall of Mirrors
so the physical world mirrors the astral
and vice versa in certain ways same with
the causal karmic same with the seventh
plane which is where our divinities hang
out mostly and it's it's nice because
then we can use one reality our main
third dimensional physical reality as a
mirror and a bit of a map for
understanding everything else so how do
we use the three-dimensional reality as
a mirror for the fourth dimension how
does that work how does that mirror yeah
so I use healing because that's
something most of us have access to so
if you see an energy healer somebody
who's actually
really skilled has some good trainings
been practicing for yours their clients
say good things about them not just
somebody who says who I do energy
healing or I got a ricky initiation but
who actually does it and you come to
that healer this is something that
happened to me actually a couple years
ago I had this intense pain in my wrist
and they said you know what's up what's
with the anatomy the tendon is the
ligaments the tissues the fashion of the
muscles all of it did I do something and
they said put your awareness on your
wrist and I put my awareness inside my
wrist and immediately all these visions
came to me of some past trauma which I
don't want to get into in detail I can't
if you're curious and as soon as I felt
that wasn't stop trying to avoid them
avoidance is a huge topic and in a lot
of types of healing and I allow that
energy to finally be processed and I
stopped and resisting it the pain
actually went away to about an 80% I
think it's a really critical to measure
this stuff very few people do and then
the next day maybe two or three percent
was left like a ghost of a remembrance
but it was all gone no no physical
contact whatsoever all awareness mm-hmm
and so you can say if you want to stick
strictly 3d as a strict skeptic oh you
just found a great way to engage the
placebo effect and all the stuff is an
anchor for that and if all you want to
do is stay super super grounded and only
this reality then yeah magic is just
taxed as a placebo effect which is
pretty much unlimited it can cause
cancer can reverse cancer but when you
get into that after all you start
explaining the mechanism of action you
start explaining that tingling the
warmth you feel when you do cheat going
for real and when an energy healer is
working on you and you can notice
something and when you get to the astral
energetic there's all these ways of
describing it Kichi prana Shen Ian
Energy on energy all this stuff what
would be the astral explanation for the
removing of the pain from your arm the
astral explanation is that the astral
world mirrors the physical one so there
is part of my soul embodied in spirited
inspired there's part of my soul in my
wrist and because we're holographic and
souls are infinite shapes and we're all
one and if you up dimensionally high
enough this television is just as much
of a soul as you or me or our hands or
these chairs but so the part of what I
believed was my soul or the soul that
the awareness was causing to focus here
with some
prep trauma something that I was
avoiding and so by really seeing that
I'm feeling that and processing that the
the draw for attention the pain left and
so that has a couple different meanings
one meaning is we can heal our bodies
through healing our spirit as the
ancient one said to dr. strange and that
excellent movie and the other one is
really looking at all this stuff as
tools for enlightenment and a very
practical very very clinical way
defining enlightenment is just you don't
really have a [ __ ] you don't really
have attachments you don't feel gripping
compulsions and emotions don't really
lock now I think enlightenment is a
continuum I think there's a lot to be
said about it that is not an exhaustive
definition but looking at that we could
say that doing that experience can take
you to you know point zero eight two
percent more enlightened you know for
one so we can summarize by saying we're
channeling our energy and our awareness
to a part of our body to focus on it to
heal it I'd use the term directing
because in a lot of systems channeling
has a specific meaning but yeah cool so
now let's touch on you said seventh
dimension ninth dimension and then we
got to get to reincarnation as well so
what yeah what are these different
dimensions fourth was astral so you can
take your energy your soul and move it
around space-time yeah okay what's five
and six and seven so the fifth the fifth
dimension in the map that I use that I
kind of an abyss isn't precise an
agreed-upon map by like what the 11th
dimension is in that string theory right
that's so every every map is written by
certain people and it's up to other
people to say yeah that's a valid map
and there's a lot of maps that we're
doing to legions and angels and we're do
spirits do you want to go there do you
want to go back to the lining v because
we can we can do either this is a three
dimensional conversations I can say at
the same time yeah it's because really
that's what's on camera we're doing more
of course where do those live as well
there just seems to be so much that
lives in what we don't know and it's
very difficult to be able to pinpoint
and describe in so I guess the first
question then is follow up on this but
there's nothing that's objectively
agreed-upon past their dimensions
true I wouldn't even say the third
dimension is objectively agreed-upon
haha you take thousand people and show
them a specific color of purple and you
take out a Sherwin Williams or Benjamin
Moore color deck with eighty shades of
purple and everybody's cones and rods
are different some people might have
macular degeneration and say can own
1000 people objectively agree that this
purple is you know quinacridone violet
thirty seven with cherries on top
there's probably gonna be one person who
says no unless they're all paid or
coerced or brainwash or something - all
agree so in terms of objective reality
something that's why you're talking
about color and I'm sitting here on this
show talking about can we get all seven
and half billion people to not kill each
other well that's actually a different
funny that you're saying you don't even
agree on a [ __ ] color that one color
is the same well yeah I mean we get
everybody who will be relaxed about it
you know what do you want people to stop
killing each other but it'd be fine
go back so do you want to touch on
Angels & Demons causal karmic objective
reality which topics we're gonna talk
about first so it's so difficult if we
don't even agree on the third dimension
yeah we agree on anything past that so
maybe then there is a supply I actually
have something to offer to you I'd say
that everything is a continuum between
subjective and objective and what is
objective you'd like the term consensus
reality so there's somebody living with
me who I was training who had a mental
health condition they went after meds I
tried to help them I couldn't pass a
certain point or at least I didn't
believe I could and therefore that was
the reality or ever you want to look at
it and eventually they ended up in a
psych ward after an intervention and a
lot of drama and that person felt that
their reality was a hundred percent true
but nobody else did they were outside of
consensus reality and so for us to say
this is black we could argue for ten
hours if it's zinc black or Mars black
the amount of gloss ultimately it
doesn't matter so if I share angels and
demons what I would have to share about
that where the nature of karma or the
fifth-dimensional calls the plane or
that I don't go to string theory 11
dimensional although I recognize that is
valid and
simultaneous paradoxical truths we can
get into their reality can get really
trippy so what we do generally is we
collapse the wave function we agree to
box certain concepts to be useful so for
example if you're talking to a
nutritionist and saying well how much
protein should I eat if I want to
maintain muscle mass and grow muscle
mass by such-and-such I'm out you'll get
different things most consensus might
say your body weight plus X and there's
other people who would say well you
don't actually need that much protein
and so what ultimately matters in in the
world that I live in and that I teach
and the validation and agreements I've
had from people who agree with this
because I'm people can agree with their
believe in whatever they want I don't
I'm not attached to people following me
or liking my stuff or agreeing with me I
just speak the truth that I see if
reality follows expectation one of the
first well-known channels was woman
named Jane Roberts and she channeled to
being named Seth or who called himself
Seth in these books
Seth speaks a series and the first was
called the nature of personal reality
the first to really make it big and a
lot of people Esther Hicks who did lot
of Attraction and they made the secret
based I'll have that story if you really
look into it her interview with Oprah
they go all into that stuff reality kind
of follows our expectations hmm
so if you expect there's something about
angels and demons and you want to
understand what is a demon what is not a
demon what is an angel what is not a D
an angel how do you work with these
beings protect yourself against them are
they projections of your inner self are
they shadows and light are they
parasites are they just concept and form
created by organizations to scare people
and they're not even real but can you
channel your thought towards things that
are not objectively true and have your
expectations go in that direction even
though there's not truth like the Flat
Earth Society yes and so then we get
into what happens when you don't share
consensus reality and so the flood of
the society I'm going to use a more
extreme example I'm going to say
interesting so then there's there's a
there's a bit of this consensus reality
and then on top of that is the more
subjective reality that's usually
outside of this third dimension and what
what the scientific method is used for
where you you have an idea you test that
idea you confirm that idea is true or
false other people can do the same thing
the scientific method in very simple
nutshell is if I say angels are export
Qi is why
and the whole world says oh that's an
interesting thought let's either test it
experimentally correct Oh compared to
the 10,000 other people who have said
that yeah and so ultimately even if it
might be very hard to get all 1,000
people agreeing on purple or get all
flat earth people on the same page as
everybody else or vice versa
ultimately what matters is how do you
use this stuff how does it apply to you
how does it apply to life in general
yeah what's the value of it and at what
point are we satisfied with the science
because science involves all the time
you can have bias people you can have
botch experiments you can have poor
methods you can have smaller sample
sizes you can have changes in the
Earth's magnetic field you can have
different interpretations of language
you can have so many varying factors no
we're understanding that consciousness
affects reality the Princeton pear lab
and Stanford labs and so many people
measure consciousness look at some
consciousness as a factor I only just
finished real quick with consciousness
as a factor it gets really tricky in
terms of measuring experimental
experimental results so you could test
well penicillin kill certain types of
bacteria and a petri dish sure will a
same amount of penicillin or whatever
antibiotic killed the same infection in
different bodies say their exact clone
body's identical twins live the same
life one person is an optimist the other
is a pessimist and because of that from
all the research we know about stress
the optimist has a higher t-cell count
and the penicillin or whatever
antibiotic does better in their body and
then they're healthier with the
microbiome afterwards so it really it
really boils down to precisely what
we're looking at and why and so to step
back a second and to not get so meta
because you can just get lost in that
entire life that was a really good
example of not meta so is that a
Princeton or Stanford or where was that
Stanford has s RI and Princeton had the
pair lab which which close unfortunately
and in Petaluma there's the Institute of
Medical Sciences or ion noetic Sciences
and then and then what's the SR I stand
for again I believe Stanford Research
and Research Institute and then that
they have a consciousness division
within oh they had a lot of
organizations aren't publicly about this
stuff anymore because because it's tough
to study something that's so outside of
the third so that's a really good shape
that's actually not tough there's a lot
of reasons political and industrial and
cultural one example that people can
find if they google it is a guy named
Russell
park was paid a ton of money by the CIA
to look into this topic of remote
viewing / astral projection depending on
the system cool and he beat the silver
market and got profiled in The Wall
Street Journal
for accurately predicting the silver
market now he had all these things that
it could be for personal gain it had to
be for the benefit of the world but he
was able to do something in a way that a
major mainstream publication said yes
this is legit so the question isn't what
science is that there today that you can
find and walk into a lab and say you
know show me how you can levitate this
cat or show me what she is and prove it
as true or false so that the whole James
Randi thing which I don't want to get
into it seems to be the slow tournament
into as much objectivity within the
subjective realm as possible these
hypotheses being tested over time of the
fourth dimension of Ashe projection it's
less but more of the adoption so if you
take the matrix red pill blue pill and
you look at the matrix movie as a way of
looking at our reality for just a second
and you know if there's a country and
that country destabilizes people stop
paying taxes for example that country
falls apart and yeah you could say
politicians spend money in inappropriate
ways and the Justice ISM is imbalanced
and we could do a lot more for people in
poverty and and corporations could treat
their employees better all the way
societies can be improved ultimately
governments provide safety they provide
infrastructure they do good things they
do bad things if we want to use simple
words like good and bad when you give
too much information about objective
reality too much magic stuff you kind of
can mess with the system a little bit
Dean Radin who was president of ions who
founded it with Edgar Mitchell the sixth
man to walk on the moon there's a lot of
interesting stuff about him if you look
and some of the the deep parts of the
web one of the things that Dean said and
he just wrote an interesting book called
real magic I agree with some of it don't
agree with some of it he said he said to
me once we were talking if magic were
ubiquitous the world would last 30
minutes and if you look into her my eyes
I'm about to explain if you look into
her medics or the book called the
Cavalia and her medics is Egyptian magic
Thoth ascended master of reading writing
language math if you look into her
medics her medic says high level masters
can start or stop earthquakes which is
believable
you have really high-level ascended
masters like Babaji and autobiography of
a yogi' they got he wrote
that was Steve Jobs or any scientist
would pretty much say that you're crazy
sure because it's really hard to get
that in a lab because how do you have a
lab that can encompass an area and prove
the causal link from consciousness to
the earth but not just consciousness to
the earth
anyone can say I'm feeling this tree or
I'm feeling these flowers right now but
to say that you can stop an earthquake
yeah that is a whole different category
right and so just just to tie that up
before saying the problem with science
related to this let's take for a second
that that's possible if you trained
everybody to do that and took away the
mystery and mystery schools you know if
you get ticked off from somebody cutting
you off on traffic or you get ticked off
at your neighbor you know the world
turns to ash you're very very sure okay
okay so then that's the idea is that
there would be unleashing of power from
within people yeah okay so all right
let's let's go let's go back just a
little bit because this is all extremely
cool and it's so it's a lot to wrap
people's minds around that have been
just chilling in the 3d plane and you're
trying to figure it out alright so
initially you were mentioning past
life's present lights of future lifes
alright because we still need to get
into magic rail and everything but tell
us about reincarnation
how does astral projection relate to my
ability to go into my past life this is
a fun topic and this is one that
actually has been studied deeply so the
two resources names books I'd like to
offer Larry Dossey do SS e Y his book
called one mind and Gary Schwartz this
book called the afterlife experiments
Gary Schwartz University of Arizona for
a while
Larry Agassi goes all over the place
both of these guys looked at a lot of
stuff if you just google evidence for
reincarnation and don't look at
something heavily biased there's a lot
of bias stuff you have tons of examples
of little kids remembering specific
details where they were born where they
died if they were murdered who killed
them what the murder weapon eyes was
this stuff was dug up so I really want
to tie this back into how it's practical
and valuable you know the earthquake
thing whether it's real or false
depending on what anybody believes the
value isn't very very high for most
people but the value that is high is
this past life astral projection thing
because we're talking about what are you
as a human being and what effects
quality of your life and if you talk
about enlightenment as having more of a
light body feeling more light whether
you call that light hearted whether you
call it astral you have all this energy
all this power all this bliss all this
nirvana where you just say you're at
peace you're at happiness
you're detached from the issues of the
world you might have preferences but
you're not attached to this preferences
and you are 100% in control of your
emotions if you choose to experience
them another you know very small sliver
of a secular definition of enlightenment
so the value of this stuff is to expand
your awareness and realize that you are
awareness you're a soul if you get full
awareness of a past life you realize
you're not your name you're not your job
you're not your net worth or your net
debt you're not anything related to this
life or this incarnation or that one and
you might have some trauma some habit
some preference some aversion related to
a past life how you lived how you died
how you succeeded have you failed and if
you do that a few times especially
non-human bodies which is interesting
then you start to feel this expansion
these Church realize your eternal your
immortal not saying that if you you as
Alan get shot in the head
Alan will stop walking and takling
likely he will stop walking and talking
but the you behind it inside of that
that knows he is much much greater than
that genderless formless it's a type of
liberation in a freedom which so far for
most of my life there's very very little
that can compare to that so the value of
shifting your awareness astrally not
even talking about all the dimensions
which all exist in simultaneously
overlapping to that past life where you
view it do you Remote View or you asked
for projector wareness into that other
space-time where you as Betsy Craig for
example in your butter churn with blue
turquoise shoes and married to married
to an interesting man I could just go
into those little bits that are coming
through the value the practical everyday
value 3d it's psychological how your
quality of life less suffering if you if
you're really scared of cats and you
realized in a past life a cat that had
rabies bit you and you you know murder
your children something really awful and
then killed yourself something really
terrible but you made peace with that
because you know there's billions of
people in the world everything that
can't happen
happen and will happen you come to peace
at that and now you're in longer afraid
of cats or Heights or the color red or
of loud noises and so 3d it's a
psychology technique now for the-- it's
very interesting because as betsy and
aside from butter turning maybe you were
very very very physically strong and
this life you're less strong and you can
tap into a past life
simultaneous such parallel life if you
look at time like this channel yourself
bring back that part of you that
remembered strength if you were to start
this let you see these contortionists
and people who are acrobats have
incredible strength they don't have
bulging muscles lay their arms aren't
like huge and defined they're like
sticks but they can do these things that
what people can't do it you go to yoga
you take football players in yoga they
may not have the structure and endurance
and they can't hold poses for long
periods of time that grandmother's can
hold so the other value is higher
strength so now if we go into what it
what else is the astral causal and other
value before we go on to your next topic
is what are the abilities and qualities
did you have that you can remember okay
you have the liberation you have the
inner peace which some people search
their whole lives for with a lot of
substances for better or for worse based
on how you define those words and to use
one example as a channel ron they have
some thoughts over there the substances
yeah that we can we can go into
psychedelics sometime but i want to
stand topic for how free different mind
but if you want we can switch sir you
know every time I do psychedelics the
visual is always the same but the
message is all Ron's back again Ron why
do you keep coming back here what more
do you want that we already haven't
given you yeah that's all I just wanted
to share that yeah yeah it's interesting
I mean biologically with with a little
bit of 4d astral energetic and some
chief stuff from China a lot of it the
tips of energy and in your body you have
Qi which is your physical energy and you
have Shen which is your spiritual energy
and there's many other types of energy
and a lot of psychedelics too a few
things they convert Qi to Shen
so they burn up your vitality which you
can replenish with food and sleep and
stuff boost into your spirit they can
expand your ro they can open your
chakras and they can sometimes release
or metabolize it to DMT which your
pineal gland if it's healthy which takes
work to get there often can release on
its own so you can see
things it's called the third eye because
it can perceive light Astra light and
other light and so you can see into
other realities the problem with drugs
because you can get to those perhaps
enhanced perceptions without them and I
have a whole model for this I teach this
all the time is it makes it really hard
to tell the difference between accurate
perception and delusion mm-hmm it gives
you access to boost your spirit and I'd
like to use a mathematical model for our
psychedelics useful and I can't legally
recommend them but I've had over 300
experiences with small doses and large
doses and I really very rarely use them
I almost never do now because I like
having the clean perception of me there
naturally so your baseline perception is
20 you can maybe maybe maybe feel Chi if
you work at it and if you take LSD
psilocybin ayahuasca iboga something
healthy in a mature responsible context
with people who have been doing this for
decades who know what they're doing I
have your best interest at heart who are
ethical like all the appropriate
safeguards you know your biochemistry
you know your heart is okay you know
it's a safe space you know all the impro
prea intelligence stuff you haven't done
it in at least a month your system your
gut is kind of pure so you're not gonna
have a negative experience that dosing
is appropriate for your biology most
people miss that big time the source is
trusted all of it you go from baseline
of 20 to say 40 and you're tripping and
you see stuff or you go to a 60 and
you're really tripping and you you know
it's not safe to like dry much less walk
in public or you go to like 80 and
you're totally wigged out and you're
speaking other languages or you're very
clearly on drugs or an altered state or
100 and you feel your unity you feel
like you're god you're the Messiah
you're all that is now if you're Shen is
expanded widely enough and there's
enough energy in your system
perceptional ii that might be true but
then you crash back down to 20 where you
were any of all the side effects of the
recovery it's like the astronauts that
go to the moon and then back and they're
like what is their life to do so how I
use stuff when I used to use it we still
do up from 20 I don't take a big dose I
only micro dose in most cases and other
cases that really prepare so I'll be at
if my baseline is just like a 40 because
I've been doing this for a long time we
need to read a unpacked a bunch of other
things yeah I want to be very calm just
wrap it up the minute I'm gonna well
because we were on it and I want to
answer a lot of people's stuff
one quick well well with
well with where we were going with
psychedelics it's a lot of it it is
about our ability to access those going
from 20 to 30 to 40 even without the
need of that but it's good to have our
mind expanded to those levels as well we
need to come back at least briefly to
reincarnation because we were talking
about the accessing past lives and how
cool that is to be able to do something
like that when one gets a pretty good
understanding of history and they start
parsing it better and better they can
almost see those time periods they can
feel those time periods they can they
can really be there exploring what those
time periods were like for civilization
now is that a is that my nervous system
taking because it's consciousness
localized in the nervous system is it
then consciousness moves from nervous
system to nervous system once it dies
how many seconds does it take to get
reborn yeah all of that interesting
stuff like that just get there for us
quick
so I'd say consciousness is generally
the software that can always be upgraded
and expanded your brain is the hardware
we always get new hardware we get new
phones every year how does the software
move from body to body Internet the
field the collected universe source
interesting so then the hardware dies
but the software goes through the fabric
of more accurately the hardware
transmute since the software which
actually matters like if you if you you
know have a really important video that
you shot that video does kind of
physically exist as data stored on
devices and you can you know beam it
through the internet and email it to
somebody and then they have that video
all the hardware can go away and that
video could still exist as you know
something beamed from one satellite to
one station or something between fiber
optic cables and the video could be
restored with new hardware existing so
while physical bodies can transmute into
other types of matter and not to be
funny with language but they don't
matter to too much okay in terms of who
you are as a soul like you cut your arm
off you're still you even though you're
a bit different your body dies you as
awareness or still
you as you expand your awareness your
body your voice your name your identity
matter less and less and less because
you realize you are so much greater I
feel like you are a very strong expert
in this understanding in these
understandings because you speak about
it very multidisciplinary which is very
difficult to to not just fall into one
vertical chamber you have a very
horizontal understanding of this but
you've also vertically went into the the
spirit so how about this because I think
this is important for people to get we
mentioned it a couple times already the
applicability of magic is real where can
we most easily apply magic being real we
were talking about pain pain in our body
being able to hone awareness to that
part of the body and heal it there what
other ways so we're we're there's two
ways of answering that there's
categorically and techniques so
categorically might be healing enhanced
perceptions abundance frequency is our
money magic internal Qigong Tantra or
working with it sexual energies those
are all different categories that are
very very practical like money magic who
like a lot of people a lot more money
money isn't good or bad it has the
judgments we can choose to place or take
away from it and so when you get to
techniques what are healing techniques
that are practical specific what our
monetary techniques so this is what I
teach in my school and my workshops and
one-on-one training somebody will come
and say oh I'd love to learn how to see
and feel energy or oh I'd love to pull
more money into my life and how do we
work on those things along with any of
that other topics I've mentioned or a
whole host of those manifestation
reality creation attracting a soulmate
for example there's the physical and
then there's a metaphysical so the
physical neurons setting goals taking
care of these physical bodies it matters
were in the 3d realm it's included in
the all of reality and then the astral
and then the causal and then all the way
up so the the practical value really
depends on your point of access if you
want to get fit say say you you're
talking to somebody that overweight and
they want to get fit very efficiently
most research I've seen says that the
fastest most efficient ways to get fit
intermittent fasting and caloric
restriction and cleaning up your diet
all right they're high-intensity
interval training or just drink training
you build up more muscle mass you burp
house of calories high knows it interval
training right if your body cannot take
high intensity interval training there's
something up with your joints or you're
in a wheelchair and you can only do
high-intensity interval training with
your upper body then your access is
different then you know you you could
say many other people you may know so
magically I always work with people
where they're at one-on-one and
generally in workshops got it and so if
you have a practical wish desire intent
we would then say okay that's in this
category these techniques are ideal for
you and then we would kind of customize
it and just like any school you have
stuff that is is shared digitally that
everybody can get to and it's mostly the
same and you can just choose what you
pay attention to and then the
customization work either the one-on-one
work or how you individually choose to
customize what you learn for yourself
are there any blanket advice for yeah
there's a ton yeah let's get some
blanket advice I'd say if somebody wants
to study magic and they never hear
anything for me again it's a the most
critical thing is to look for validation
it's to look for consensus reality so if
you think you could slaughter a pig and
draw its blood in certain shapes and
you're gonna have people flocking to
knock down your door and hug you and
kiss you you know good luck but if you
think you can pray and really deeply
connect with the divine and people will
knock down your door clog and kiss you
also good luck if however you really
truly deep down believe one of those two
hopefully the praying and connecting
with the higher being Jesus Moses Buddha
any Mary Magdalene any any a high level
spiritual being a divinity you can
connect with or the one god if that's
your philosophy and a lot of people a
lot of sources have also validate that
inconsistence reality then you can grow
in power or grow an impact grow and
power a little more ways so say you want
more more love more people to hug you
you want more money you want better
faster healing if you work in a system
that other people have validated then
it's much more likely to be successful
and you're much more likely to grow in
power and complexity so you want to
learn how to heal wounds
possibly affect the Raider healing pace
of cancers strengthen people physically
strengthen you emotionally you could
take Tibetan Buddhism you could take
Reiki you could take acupuncture all of
those are very big systems and there's a
lot of people who have said and written
love now they've gotten diluted and
there are less credible people who say
they think they know what they're
talking about and they may not but the
good thing is if you're a scientist and
a researcher you can find out the truth
for you so the most concise one takeaway
it say is if you if you feel like you're
a seeker and you want a truth a
technique be broad be general just like
if you want to know the truth of what's
what happened and it's a political issue
it serves you best to read a liberal
perspective a conservative perspective
and independent perspective multiple
perspectives to get to the objective
truth that consensus truth to get the
most data that you can mmm that's the
first thing and I can go on but that's
great that's a big that's a big one and
that's a good analogy and that's what
I've done Allen over the years 28 years
I've studied magic in different forms
I'm biologically 33 since I was five
just been like focusing on it and
looking where does she go overlap with
Kabbalah for example where does
Hermeticism overlap with Christian
Science or Christian mysticism what
stuff is mythological and metaphorical
that we can draw from and interpret and
which is kind of like scary stuff or
politically added-on or culturally or
one person at it and it isn't really
real and then how do we test this in our
own bodies and how does all this stuff
linked how is karma useful as a concept
how does seeing karma something that
doesn't need to exist a useful concept
what is belief what is expectation was
faith what is love and exploring all
this and looking at all the other
definitions and then synthesizing that
is something I've I've really really
tried to to do and then when I when I
channel I'm interviewing right now
mentally as David Solomon when I channel
and how your source or self or aliens or
ascended masters or divine beings come
through me with whatever percent my ego
filter can come through I know there's a
lot to unpack there but just roll with
me then there's there's much more
definiteness like I call it an ego
filter that seems like a really good way
to put it it's so huge if you look into
channeling and spirit science has a cool
video on it there's a consciousness
consciousness not in the body say you
know demigod Allen realizes himself
herself their self as an expanded soul
that's had 400 lifetimes and you're
aware of all those simultaneously you
have demigod awareness just to use that
very sparse definition for now just to
make it up make it very simple and I
want to channel you know in channel
demigod Allen and then you gotta Allen
says how to take care of myself or your
the voice of my intuition I hear your
voice in my head and you're the voice
when I when I write re-type and I say
hey I'm channeling demigod Allen how do
we know that's true it work might work
for me and the information might be
useful the cool thing about channeling
is people have channeled like specific
stars yeah and that's been validated
other people do it or remote viewing
you'll have multiple people remote view
the contents of an envelope double-blind
stuff and they'll get it right we're
like a nuclear silo somewhere across the
world that hasn't been released and
those people had a well I love viewing
other habitable planets orbiting stars
that's fun I've done that yeah yeah so
getting into the practical that useful
with the karmic and with with like all
this stuff and the simultaneous lives
and channeling when you channel it's you
know if you vow are that if you are one
with the universe in in theory but until
I can levitate that television I'm not
that television as much as I'm this arm
because I don't believe it or else
they'll be levitating right now just as
if I don't believe I'm one with gravity
even though conceptually nine
dimensionally that's true just to answer
the paradoxes that don't really seem to
make sense an everyday speech which is
one thing I've really worked on is
deconstructing paradoxes I think what
you were describing earlier is a key
point which is taking in all of this
different these different sources of
information into your being so that way
you can have as much of a consensus
objective understanding of what's going
on in the world as possible so whether
that be with 3d reality we live in or
once you start trying to fluctuate into
what exists outside of it tapping into
as many of the sources as possible
talking to other people learning about
their practices continuing to work on
yourself over time in that in the energy
fields that exist outside of the 3d and
it's it's very cool to unpack this with
you and I think we're just just we're
only at the tip of the iceberg and the
rest is all below the water and there's
so much there and it's pretty much
beyond the lines of perception
what goes underwater and it's really
difficult to try and dig those pieces of
the iceberg out
it's a connect into what is beyond this
this this flush vehicle existence I love
being able to talk to you about and I
feel like again we're just it's so
difficult for people at home to to
practically put this into play and I
just want to say that you know a lot of
really good ways to practically put it
into play are to are to to just go with
the meditation there you are the magic
is real yeah would you like a brief
answer to your ego filter and how that's
would love to the ego filter Sophia
fastening it seems like a lot of what it
would exist outside of the 3d comes down
to the ego at the 3d and then the ego
prevents from the 3d upward the Eagle
filter here prevents interestingly
enough we use the singular term ego but
it's actually plural like the ego of all
seven half billion people mmm
differently but yes okay so Elaine for
Jay who is a man in France who people
have reportedly seen white lights
hovering around validated whoo a friend
and teacher of mine study is with Elaine
and he can mess with your perceptions
make everything dark except him very
interesting stuff like really affecting
you through your senses no drugs or
plant medicines or whatever so he uses a
term I've seen in many places it's a
great term it's called subpersonalities
so if you think about the type of you
who you are in front of your grandmother
versus your lover versus your ex that's
versus your parent versus your child
self when you're angry when you're not
angry dumb in her down in her is a place
in northern Italy they use an Atlantean
magical tradition I've studied with
quite a bit they they talk about this as
different components of you so in the
Chinese system anger is associated with
the liver and liver energies you're
feeling angry you're feeling frustrated
so tying all this stuff together one of
you in a past life maybe the part of you
that is Genghis Khan or Alexander the
Great or Napoleon or or Hitler or
Mussolini or whoever that part of you
that you can access
that has anger then acts on that anger
may be embodied in your liver and the
process of at one mint atonement
integration completion is you loving and
accepting all of that and feeling it and
shadow integration work and all that
stuff not necessarily expressing it as
the first idea that might come in with
that signature but seeing it all is one
so when channeling comes through like
the being which knows itself as David
Solomon born as David Celinda that being
has certain preferences and certain
thoughts and certain diversions and when
that being allows himself to step to the
side higher stuff can come through and
when you look at an ego filter and you
look at the truth of what's channeled a
truth of the capital T right yeah you
could say Jesus was a being who had a
very very small ego filter but a large
and consistent ego because that ego was
generally always consistent but there
was no attachment and what flowed
through with source was not subverted by
a personality trying to be liked yeah
you're trying to be appreciated right so
if if David's channeling and something's
coming through and David wants to be
liked or wants to feel smart or wants
something else to come through then
David is essentially blocking the
transmission yes and the filter is at
ten percent or ninety percent or
whatever so when when David says look at
thirty sources for stuff like this
unless you really feel that's true
within you that's that's a knowing of
hey there could be a filter present
because of the nature of ego it's a bit
self-defeating to say the ego filter is
one percent or 80 percent present
there's you know some accuracy but it's
a very personal thing and generally no
one can know except the being speaking
and as you're experiencing reality the
more that you enable yourself to fullest
actualization without wanting to be
liked or wanting money or thinking about
that this or that these these these
external materialistic consumptive
aspects the more you're actually
challenged channeling this authentic
being through what's existing outside of
the 3d quick just to probably let's as
the as the lasting let's make this the
lasting and then
if you want to end or something go ahead
and believe it we'll keep it quick sure
Robert Sapolsky wrote a book called
behave and I think this is very
interestingly aligned with what you're
speaking about because if all of the
evolutionary forces that have led up to
today are what I experienced in my life
as in I have all these bacterial cells
within me that control me in ways I
don't know I have these tendencies from
either my genetics or my epigenetics or
my past lives that have been that have
been brought into me today that this
sort of I'm very interested in how these
two things overlap apolskis behave and
how you think that every moment you're
in control but really it's been these
last billions of years of evolution that
have put what you are on the planet and
what you could what you think you have
free will over you really don't that
much intertwined with what exists
outside of this 3d reality I think those
interestingly have really cool they do
and I have a I'll be concise so I
there's a few terms I like with this the
first is surrender and the other one is
fractal line Dominion so surrender is
kind of easy to understand my key sigil
wrote a great book
Mickey Siegel called the surrender
experiment talking all about
surrendering to the flow surrendering to
the Divine Will
Yogananda job this grew out of a graffia
yoga author talked about surrendering to
Ishwara
aspect of divine will yeah that's a way
to unlock the power of flight by the way
which that's a whole story about demons
and angels and transmissions and visions
in prophecy but specifically fractal
everything's a fractal Dominion
dominance so you have a heart your heart
has its own agency it can act on its own
you through breathing through nutrition
through a force of will can affect the
behavior of your heart your heart has
dominion over the blood in your body you
have dominion over your heart in your
blood so your whole body has agency you
have agency over it it's not too far
elite to believe yourself a cell in the
body of God or a heart of the great
goddess and so with that you have
surrender what is my purpose to plump
pump blood what is my purpose to be a
messenger of and help raise the power of
magic in the world
and having my own agency as your heart
does how's your mitochondria do as your
microbial organisms do theirs the
components of free well within certain
bounds
what ascension is or path iosys is and
it's in all cultures there's the
apotheosis of George Washington founder
of this country went through the process
or at least worked on that is your
awareness raises so you no longer this
cell you're the heart you're the body
you're the body of bodies you're the
awareness beyond bodies that's Ascension
and if you have an ascended master who
kills somebody or helps a plant grow
really quickly and people can do this
even if they're not ascended masters
I've I've had the fortune of witnessing
that occurring through me I like that
more than from me there's there's a
bunch of reasons for that or other
people whoever you see it at the moment
where it happens or when it was raining
and awareness shifted and then it wasn't
raining or the opposite or animals were
allowed and awareness shifted animals
weren't loud or there was no smell we're
gonna shift didn't there was smell
I was the animal I was the rain I was
the cloud and the body and the awareness
and the other stuff so that's the higher
level you if you want power if you want
ability for the purpose of realizing
yourself as divine not for parlor tricks
in it for impressing people not for
distraction which are a lot of common
objections if you really want that power
to remind yourself and demonstrate it
and not everyone does and that's the
value of the past life astral projection
yes of knowing yourself as greater than
a finite mortal being yes yeah yes and
that but that's I love thinking about it
that way because we are greater than
this finite mortal being so many think
that it's just death and that's it and
that whatever happens happens
but thinking about and tapping into what
exists outside of it and what it's a
crazy process and it's very difficult to
put words behind words are so limiting
feelings are even limiting in this sense
it's very difficult to unpack and what
we only started right and is there
something else like to end with that
yeah there's one thing that I would love
to add so I help people develop art your
natural psychic abilities and Paul C
Lagasse lig excellent author channels he
melchizedek many many books teaches
clairvoyance clairaudience words yeah
synonyms cultural interpretations
translations if you want the true bible
do you know aramaic as well as you know
the earliest people or do you take the
the other stuff throughout the cultural
cultural perspectives so uh we're in a
world of vibration we're in a world of
source and that vibration gets
translated sometimes then accurately you
could say ego filter you could say
vocabulary if you have a
fourteen-year-old with excellent
vocabulary words they haven't even read
that's channeling if you have somebody
who's 70 giving a great intellectually
Laden lecture that could be on mind or
that could be all channeled so it's very
interesting looking into this but
remembering that all is vibration that
this physical world is the grossest the
most dense the most overt the least
subtle so if you think about subtlety
and flirting and if I look at you and I
say hey you want to sleep together
that's not very subtle but if I look at
you and give you a look that's a little
bit more subtle more subtle still is a
bit of vibration where are you picking
up you don't even see me across the room
you think I might be flirting with you
and this could go for any any person any
scenario so how high up do you go that's
the dimensional model mm-hm
and so if you want truth realize that
language is only one sphere of truth and
it can only represent and so all the
people who talk about enlightenment
Nirvana Samadhi Satori is indescribable
is because the words of language failed
to capture the essence of the whole yep
and now a good way to again tap into
this is to try and meditate try and feel
try and really if you feel something in
your body
just take the time to experiment with
what it's like to draw your attention to
that place and just play around and
things like this when you hear astral
projection think about what is it like
if I try and move my mind right now to a
different city or near my mother or near
somebody else in the world how would
that feel like if I try doing that just
practicing these things and slowly
inching our way forward thank you
everyone for tuning in
thank you David sure for joining us let
me give a few websites for people who
want to learn this but let's do it cool
so grateful I want them to bio as well
yeah Thanks so great website to learn at
astral projection slash remote viewing
is probable future com
excellent trustworthy last I checked 250
bucks this if you go straight there
magic money health calm is under
construction smoke my website I have a
wizard school and blogs and book
previews there you know my book magic is
real you know patreon.com slash magical
joy of exclusive content awesome ways of
teaching people a little magical
techniques and the facebook is
facebook.com/paes
anybody wants to help always happy to
take names yeah exactly so well the
content is now up we will go ahead and
have the links in the bio for you to
check out definitely tap into david
sources as well obviously for so much
time that somebody has invested into
being able to understand these things it
would be a great way to go through him
to be able to to tap into it ourselves
as well so David thank you so much sure
this is only the beginning only the
beginning yeah so much more left yeah
yeah and it's beautiful to go into this
process of like of digging and
understanding and feeling it's so rich
and gooey and it could be really fun
like we didn't get into fun silliness
but when you astral travel and you can
see intergalactic unicorns spitting the
Rays and the rings of Saturn and playing
music as DJs and having levitating cats
fart sprinkles that turn into
butterflies trail colors that turn into
planets where you have dominion of and
you can fly in chocolate pudding and and
you know more and more and more that was
the craziest stream of consciousness we
can do that for an hour next time I
don't you know that was the crazy stream
of consciousness guys thank you so much
for tuning in if you had a good time
with this content give it a share please
give it a share give us to subscribe hit
that subscribe button join us join our
family join our movement to talk about
thought-provoking things and get more
people inspired to build the future
comment below some of your thoughts as
well we'd love to hear from you and
engage with you join us on patreon we
need to support the studio's support the
lighting support the production's forth
food support everything grow join us
grow with us patreon.com force that
simulation series thank you Ron Vargas
are producing partner and we will talk
to you guys soon
please
[Music]
[Music]
you